c'est la fin idéale
j'ai un contrat son journal pour lire
les nouvelles j'espère qu'elles seront
chauds sociaux tels voyages grand
portail et balsillie sous coucy des
petits commérages eu de très grosses
auteurs
le petit écho de la forêt certains
trouveront s'est déroulé il y à toutes
les informations à chaque nouvelle
édition on n'a jamais de dissection ça
vous le découvrirez dans love qui
découlent de l'offre
il se passe décidément toujours quelque
chose dans notre jolie forêt mais oui
mais oui
écoutez boris le loup a décidé de se
construire une maison aux enchères boris
au robuste eux
guy baril aujourd'hui finissait pas
vouloir mais construire maison
personnelle à moi pourquoi moi voudrait
voir maison comme les autres va
construire une maison avec ses bras à
agen pour le groupe et pour une maison
il te faut des poutres des briques des
portes des fenêtres pas des branches il
me faut boulot je pense que bezos que
moi vouloir me construire
c'est un lieu ne tuez pas un oiseau pour
te faire un nid qu'ils allouent et bien
moi serait les premiers lots du monde
howard me boris était devenu fou c'est
sûr il fallait faire quelque chose
annie c'est amusant ce petit maurice a
toujours été un artiste mettant le cap
sur yves agid baril et s'installer en
haut d'un mât croix d'anzin dit pourquoi
pas qui on a bien hâte roi et moi je dis
d'un corbeau c'est normal si paris se
veut son nez elle lui
nous n'avons pas le droit de le
contrarier ça le regarde mais tous cas
été quand même inquiète elle courait du
plus vite qu'elle pût c'est-à-dire
lentement chez les frères k stores remis
à haut d'un arbre à odanak roriz boris
iv il faut il faut faire quelque chose
il faut faire quelque chose ou dans ce
tour boris construisait son nid en
chantant pour west à l'aîné en haut de
ses tableaux ouais c'est dans ma maison
comme nous avions qui veut barrer je
peux te donner un coup de bec
parce que je me connais attraction
d'animer le sigle aux mots max mois
vouloir faire ni à moi tout seul un
petit voudra cependant l'atelier des
frères k stores on ne peut pas reprocher
à boris de vouloir une maison comme tout
le monde mais pas un nu j'ai une idée
laquelle
un boris va tomber de son art avec sony
parce qu'il est trop lourd il n'aura
plus de maison c'est vrai il en vue ni
les chiens réfléchissant il réfléchir
trouver une idée et se mirent touche au
travail mes amis mes amis ne nous
regarde pas max maurice nous avait tous
à l'inauguration de son niveau c'est
très gentil de sa part
mini pourront pas y aller non nous avons
un travail à finir le tarif qu'ils m'ont
bombardé celui de régulation parce que
plus démunis pourquoi parce que ni
tomber comme abel stahl et des dehors
des faits nouveaux il met mois plus de
maison pol roger moore est très lourd
très triste et lourd de montrer aux os
et aux une isba une maison comme en
avoir 2 me sert ici qui nous transporte
à tous et brise
nous l'avons construit pour toi nous
voulions pas faire une surprise si amy
enfin moi avoir une tour tennant 28
d'année attendait ce bar attendu attendu
le cwa les flux sûr d'avoir trouvé le
nom de mon maison ninon la vita je vais
l'appeler monde uni
c'est ainsi que boris a eu tout de même
son nid décidément l'amitié la plus
honnie chose au monde n'est ce pas cher
téléphone
il ne me reste plus qu'à vous dire à
bientôt pour une prochaine édition de
notre petit écho de la force cher
téléphone
voyons les faits divers au très amusant
louis le renard remet sa maison à 9
ce qui m'étonne car notre ami louis
n'est pas très courageux et voilà qu'il
entreprend de gros travaux aurait-il
d'en changer même
fait tous ces travaux je vous être
épuisées exténué il faut que je trouve
quelqu'un d'aller faire la place
j'ai une idée où je suis russe il luis
eurodif et les frères casto bénoué dois
je m'en sortirai bientôt ce veinard qui
n'a jamais posé une voiture louis vient
d'apprendre à tout seul est la peinture
demande un beau coup de pinceau
j'apprendrai tout seul impossible mais
pourquoi mais bon un milieu à les fruits
c'est un four eux dont tu ne peux pas
réparé est à toi tu évites acheminer cet
affreux et pour perdre il faut savoir
mélanger les couleurs
tu as déjà essayé j'aime cet affreux ma
maison va tomber en ruine ne t'inquiète
pas les deux becs et yom et moi ne
viendront donne un coup de main je ne
voudrais pas abuser dans la vie il faut
savoir s'entraider ou que je suis ruse
et guillaume et edward sûrs qu'une
surprise en arrivant chez leurs amis qu
au hockey sauf que je sous mon pauvre
louis
mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive je suis
brûlé les deux pattes en voulant vous
préparez un petit déjeuner mag quel
malheur quel mal je voudrais bien vous
aider à refaire ma maison mais je ne
peux plus rien faire avec mes deux
paquebots des méfaits nous confiance on
ne doit jamais abandonner un ami dans
l'ennui et au merci merci merci j'ai
réussi ils vont faire tout le travail
que je suis et je suis encore plus rusé
que je ne pense eux et les deux frères k
stores entreprirent les réparations que
souhaitait lui le renard que penses tu
de cette porte que j'ai fait un vers
sata plages de rêve jones a oui mais je
ne voudrais pas un but 14 du désert doit
ce que j'ai misé sur temps toi mon
boulot il a ta place je revis des tuiles
ah oui je ne voudrais pas abuser
quelques jours plus tard la maison de
louis le rusé paraissait comme neuf et
les deux frères castor est épuisé vous
aurez bien faire à manger a
symboliquement
le réseau je ne peux pas bouger j'ai
plus rien dans le garde-manger
l'inquiète pas m'emballe oui allez nous
allons vite à faire des provisions et
que je suis russe eduard guillaume ne
vous dérangez pas je voudrais apporter
tout ce qu'il faut pour vous régaler au
mieux deux minutes le pique nique fut
installé sur le gazon et les deux frères
k stores comment certains se restaurer
sous l'oeil à sam et de l'ouïe de ruse
et mordant louis est peu de fromage
il ne peut pas manger c'est très mauvais
attendant les biens brûlés n'est ce pas
louis la risée boxe comme ans abusée à
une belle grappe de raisin bien mûres
mon bon louis voulait la tuer c'est très
mauvais quand on avait brûlé n'est ce
pas nous effrayer box continue un buso
au même pas un petit verre de se venger
de frais la question tout le monde sait
que j'ai horreur d'abuser qui devient
enfin raisonnable figure toi mon pauvre
louis que je croyais que tu avais fait
semblant d'avoir les mains brûlées pour
ne pas travailler va jamais chez louis
et te croyais plus rusés lui le renard
quand il fut seul se jeta sur les restes
du repas il mange à toutes étant qu'il
fut vraiment malade
cette fois encore il avait abusé on est
toujours puni par où on a péché n'est ce
pas cher téléphone
à bientôt pour une nouvelle édition du
petit écho de la forêt voyons voyons
quelles sont les nouvelles taxes le
corbeau ne veut plus se laisser voler
son fromage
je veux qu'il n'a pas oublié le bon au
tour que lui a joué louis leur honneur
il y a quelques années que cela sans
vous on dirait une odeur de fromage au
salut max il fait beau aujourd'hui tu es
devenu muet et qu'est-ce que tu tiens
dans ton bec
mon travail est cette fois ci tu ne
l'auras à max avait parlé et le fromage
était tombé dans la bouche de louis qui
se sauve en l'emportant cette fois ci
j'ai eu encore us pour max quand je fus
rusu dont jour louis caisse encore voile
et le fromage de taxes oui il n'est pas
en russie
trois longs prés et tosca parti le plus
vite qu'elle pût avec le fromage qu'elle
avait dérobé à louis auquel est cette
chose ronde et blanches posées devant
vous et vous allez manger cette
abomination
il paraît que c'est délicieux manger ce
fromage si vous avez envie de mourir
fromage serait-il un poison pour les
tortues oui mais je ne savais pas selon
le lex et mademoiselle de la cigogne en
main le fameux fromage pour le savourer
chez elle mais au détour d'un chemin
mais le la cigogne faut de terribles
marbre est en train de manger toutes vos
graines de millet grillé quoi et zip
lelièvre d'état là le fromage en bouche
pour trouver une cachette derrière un
bus aux voix avait dit mon chien vibre
tu vas faire un repas de roi
tout le monde rêve fromage et c'est toi
qui va qualifier la ligne d'eau c'est
moi pour moi oui y'a pas dû mais je
croyais bien
cependant l'état moi je regarde la gare
des bus le lou n'a pas peur de paris
selon moi être le mal ah non moi dévorer
ses bons fromages ou au fromage sentir
bizarre wimax m'isole tient goy de
petits morceaux
merci soit être en papier je n'ai pas pu
bien guti citons fromage était bon on va
vers well as autres petits morceaux
sans parisse ce fromage avait un goût
bizarre
baboo dessus vous ne saurez vous deviner
ou de goût de polo j'ai trouvé ce
fromage avec un bo9 et c'est ainsi que
max a réussi à manger le fromage que
louis le renard lui avait dérobé un
malin malin et demi n'est ce pas cher
téléphone
alors à bientôt faire amis pour une
prochaine édition du petit etc ou de la
force ou mademoiselle de la cigogne veut
faire un procès un procès bien eh bien
je me demande pourquoi ils vous aussi
certainement offertes et les femmes
[Musique]
ce coup
mademoiselle m'a demandé vous voilà
enfin au diable et tu voues doom et je
faisais la sieste l'un sieste vous
n'avez pas honte mais nous la fait bien
vous apprenez à pertinent que je ne fais
jamais la sieste pour dams et de congé
dans un hamac
je ne suis pas couché je repousse donc
vous faites la sieste
sinon je vous dis que je repose
si je repos c'est que je sens que je
vais mourir
ah tiens pourquoi parce que je deviens
un meuble tout est sombre autour de moi
je le vois plus les rayons du soleil les
mais moi je ne sais pourquoi vous croyez
mais de so non mais je vois clair vous
avez des lunettes de soleil sont au bec
alors rendez vous voyez tout en noir si
j'ai mis des lunettes de soleil digne
euros c'est parce que j'ai un abominable
molle [ __ ] pourquoi parce que depuis
des jours et des jours j'attends des
nouvelles des frères k stores et je n'en
puisse plus on n'est qu'à cela ne tienne
le real et wau il entend des bibles sip
lelièvre partie ventre à terre à
l'atelier des deux frères k stores alors
que penses tu de nos plein nous avons
prévu tous que mademoiselle de la
cigogne êtes mince et aux wallons ne
s'est pas fait à ce que j'ai dit elle
sera ravie enfanté jeu court vu montrer
leur travail des vip et jyp lelièvre
reparti ventre à terre chez mademoiselle
de la cidob alors manon havel est
satisfaite satisfaites ou aux pauvres
très bon tort taisez-vous pour
m'installer dans la forêt et j'ai décidé
de faire restaurer cette maison de
famille qui existe depuis les sièges
baquets oui vous osé appeler vieille
baraque
un monument historique une maison qui
m'a vue d'être dans cette comédie et le
napoli est réel
insultes mais c'est impossible
inimaginable effroyable où je sens que
je vais me trouver mal desquels une
retrouver ses esprits mademoiselle de la
cigogne se rendit sans tarder chez les
deux frères castro
mais mademoiselle c'est vous qui nous
avait demandé toutes ces transformations
à la fois comme un c pas consolider les
fondations de votre médecin
apprenez jeunes incapables que ma maison
à résister aux tremblements de terre aux
tempêtes à la neige au verglas
elle pourra très bien résisté à vos
travaux oui mais théoriquement pour
respecter nos pleins les plats
parlons-en
je n'en veux plus de mon plan est
pourquoi d'un parce que ma maison est
très bien comme et les si vous prétendez
la transformer et je vous attaquent en
dommages et intérêts quelques jours plus
tard pose en avoir longuement discuté
les deux frères caster aux airs se
présenter à la demeure de mademoiselle
de la cigogne qui yat il encore
eh bien nous avions travaillé nuit et
jour pour et a blessé plein et mais
n'avons nous laisser en plan j'ai eu une
idée pour vos plans jeunes gens ah oui
faites en des cocottes en papier voilà
au mais ça ne se passera pas comme ça
nous allons vous faire un procès en
dommages intérêts et bien moi je vous en
ferai à l'autre un autre en dommages et
intérêts et pourquoi d'en avoir osé
demander des dommages et intérêts
maintenant vous pouvez disposer dans
votre intérêt d'ici des bancs cette
chaire cigogne est de très mauvaise foi
elle a bien tort
n'est ce pas chercher les femmes de
toute façon je vous donne rendez vous
pour une nouvelle édition du petit écho
de la forêt oh excusez moi certaines
femmes mais je sais j'ai d'abord ce qui
est arrivé à fifi la fourmi alors fusé
mois et sept jours et m me
âgé de nettoyage ils leur courage et
notamment la bible et toi y'a pas que ma
maison soit la plus propre de la forêt
il y va de la réputation des fourmis
mais quel travail
j'ai déjà tirés des parcs et encaustique
et mes meubles laver les carreaux les
cils et mes peintures
qu'en reste t il à faire j'oubliais il
faut que je sois comme étape et c'est un
support dans mademoiselle de la cigogne
avait décidé de son côté de faire sa
culture physique quotidienne extension
des ailes
on respire l'extension de la patte
droite on respire
extension de la patte gauche
on respire mademoiselle de la cigogne
passait devant la maison de fifi juste
au moment où celle-ci se coincer tapis
par la fenêtre mais les voyages et le
ramassage et le décrochage est le degré
talent est là de couette
j'aime le maroc vous n'avez attrapé un
rhume almaz et de la cisaille du tout
fifi si votre poussière de quel
poussière parlez vous où voyez vous dire
que mes tapis sont remplies de poussière
évidemment plus que voulait ce coin
jusqu'où mais tapie c'est justement pour
les empêcher d'avancer la poussière
parce que moi je déteste la poussière et
puis j'adore battre les tapis c'est très
amusant
cela me fait trop d'exercices c'est
excellent et aimerait bien continuer
une cigogne la dire à tous ses amis ce
qu'elle venait d'apprendre
décidément notre fille a de drôles de
manille et qu'elle manie elle prétend
qu'elle adore battre les tapis elle a
dit ça il trouve que c'est un peu sans
et que cet excellent pour sa santé elle
nous raconte des histoires mois awards
quelle bonne idée cherbourg ici ce qui
fit fille aimait tant battre le tapis
moi allez les portes et opium moi c'est
ce que je vais faire aussi et nous aussi
moi aussi si bas est trop fort
va au moins de temps qu'il n'en faut
pour le dire
un amoncellement de tapis s'entassent à
devant la porte de fifi la fourmi et
mademoiselle de la cigogne tir à la
sonnette et l'arrêtent modèle vous avez
fini votre entraîneur physique mais vous
vous avez fini votre ménage royer
malheureusement pourquoi malheureusement
parce que je m'ennuie que je n'ai rien à
faire là et vous pourriez secoué bon
tapis
je les ai déjà sur coup et 10 fois et si
vous en aviez d'eau si j'en avais dehors
du lycée mois les stepway une liste
cours acadiens vous savez que je suis
une fille une fille une fée et si vous
avez un voeu à formuler
je voulais exaucerait tout de suite août
si tout de suite je ne peux rien serait
dit tout ce qu'il me faut vous venez de
me dire que vous n'aviez plus de ta
pièce coup il est vrai et si j'en
voulais vous voilà porteriez à l'instant
mais ne manquera pas une fille qu'est ce
que je risque est bien belle fait je
voudrais je voudrais pas tous les tapis
de la forêt ce cui à bach à l'abri
abracadabra ces tapis
les voilà mais c'est une horreur
pourquoi vous m'aviez dit que vous
adoriez secoué les tapis mais quand vous
trouviez s'amuser et que c'était
excellent pour votre santé
alors de quoi vous plaignez-vous tôt
rien que tient remercier mois plus tôt
merci bon courage
ou plutôt amusez vous bien et c'est
pauvre fille fille du ce coin tous les
tapis de la forêt pendant des journées
entières en disant qu'elle adorait ça il
arrive à tout le monde de raconter des
histoires n'est ce pas cher téléphone qu
à bientôt
je compte sur vous pour la prochaine
édition du petit etc ou de la forêt à
voyons la page des sports auront un
grand championnat de course à pied tous
cas la tortue favorite
on met très intéressant voyant sur qui
vais-je parier nous
le choix est délicat n'est ce pas cher
téléphone
moi je mise sur zip pascal a battu la
dernière côte chose simple coup de
chants pas mieux surtout ce qu emma
survivent et moi sur tosca bourriche
lellouche surveillait l'autre et mot de
tout ce qu'a dit le chronomètre
1h03 du sol dur s'ils gagnent 2
centièmes possible mais zimpfer parcours
à 7 minutes 9/10 je n'ai pas dit mon
dernier mot
de son côté mademoiselle de la cigogne
s'occuper de zips lelièvre cinq minutes
6/10 bravo des bibles jeu les red eagle
il est là pour autant cela la tension
rien ne sert de courir on cherche il
faut partir à point si on m'avait déjà
dit c'est l'année dernière serait droit
de tourner mais non mademoiselle on
reprend l'entraînement aller où les que
les modèles il le grand jour du
championnat
arriva est très vite cher téléphone j'ai
pris la tête de la course devant david
jaffe le plus fort et d'être plus la
peine de vous préciser je suis sûr de
remporter la course
eh bien allons y abbassi gérer le temps
je verrais bien une petite sieste mais
tout bas je d'oise
[Musique]
l'egypte est en train de dormir menu de
fou
[Musique]
en plus qu sieber dormant mais tu ne
peux pas on fait comme tout le monde j
-p
sip il ne faut pas que je perde la
course cette année
de quoi auriculaire sauf qu'à laisse-moi
zippé en paix cette cour ne la gagnerai
quand vous voudrez et tosca cher
téléphone quand qui doit sa course
lentement mais sûrement
[Musique]
savez vous où est passé notre chèr vie
petite reine
je les doubler tout à l'heure et qu'est
ce que tu veux dire je les laisser sur
place évidemment moi j'en ai bien
attrition les supporters de zips cherté
les femmes partir à sa recherche
et quand ils le trouvaient endormi sous
les églantiers mais en phase il peut
vous rêvez jahier n'aurait non tu t'es
un dormi panatta concurrentes continue à
courir ou pas d'affolement sphère
publique lieu des revenus ne peut pas
courir mais elle peut gagner impossible
je fais le plus rapide mais enfin si
paul biya lui sert de courir il faut
partir à point
c'est justement qu'il avait dit et j'ai
pu faire tous les fans des marins comme
une fusée j'ai gagné des malheureux tu
as perdu suite à bobino bien trois
secondes que tosca franchi la ligne
d'arrivée il a encore perdu cette fois
ci alors là bravo tu feras tu es la plus
forme
je dois le reconnaître et comment es tu
fais c'est tout simple je n'ai jamais
oublié le conseil de ma grand mère
qu'elle vient de donner des tags envers
attend que je me souvienne elle me
disait colis c'est ça
rien ne sert de courir il faut partir à
quoi et oui ce pauvre type a encore
perdu la course contre la tortue
pourtant il a toutes les qualités pour
faire un grand champion mais jude un
grand défaut
la trop confiance en lui et tpe en tout
cas je vous dis à bientôt pour une
nouvelle édition du petit écho de la
forêt verte et les fans voici une
nouvelle qui ne manque pas de
pittoresque mademoiselle de la cigogne a
décidé d'écrire ses mémoires mais oui
mais autrement dit elle va nous raconter
sa vie où on était à nouveau cr c'est le
titre de vos mémoires ah oui il me faut
un très beau titre un titre qui
intéresse au lecteur un titan qui le
fascine titre qui habite requis soit à
d'être exactement alors trouvé le
l'ignorons caunoise elle m'excuse ce
n'est pas moi et des mémoires fait vous
moi je suis contre humble secrétaire ont
décidément si je ne fais pas tout moi
même
alors je me concentre d'accord des
vessies vous permet tout le monde je ne
pourrais jamais le trouver votre mot du
titre dit c'est pas le bien c'est le
vôtre j'ai trouvé aussi laurence vous
dis-je en parlant tout vous me troubler
et vous me fait perdre la mémoire c'est
embêtant
quoi donc hé bé de perdre la baignoire
quand on écrit ses mémoires c'est un mot
tout le petit monde de la forêt avait
appris que mademoiselle de la cigogne
écrivait ses mémoires
on en parlait partout surtout que les
frères k stores incroyable mais vrai
pourquoi elle était à ses mémoires parce
qu'elle s'était crir non elle dit que
deep le lièvre
ainsi je voulais j'en aurai aussi
beaucoup à dire alors laissez-nous un
possible et pourquoi pas je n'ai pas les
moyens de m'offrir un secrétaire mois
cependant ce faisant les cent pas
mademoiselle de la cigogne ne trouvait
toujours pas le titre de ses mémoires
zip zip à associer toutes les belles
alors écrivez les trolls et autres
titres wii mémoire son titre bon je
prends un titre
désormais cela on sera un bon mémoire
fentes et trois chapitres 1 ça p 3
ah voilà évident ce chapitre doit
commencer par ma naissance
c'est très important la naissance je
vais donc raconter comment je suit et
comment j'ai grandi comme en toutes
zones cigogne est j'ai étonnez-vous
l'entourage par m'aideront nous
relativisons somme aboutit sublime mais
la nasa n'a avancé
mais comment le commencer vous ce
chapitre 1 par ma naissance je viens de
vous le dire c'est toujours intéressant
une mission aussi dit au vent bien
mademoiselle je vous lis tu écrivais
très visiblement surtout que je puisse
me relis bien mademoiselle je suis né nu
en cocon
d'accord elle venait ça ne vous regarde
pas mais vos lecteurs s'ils sont bien
élevés ils ne chercheront pas à
connaître ma date de naissance mais ça
peut les intéresser non écrivait je suis
mais où
et ensuite ensuite quoi et bah vous
étonner quand ce que vous êtes petit
hugo pauvres aussi mais des mémoires
doivent être pressé et pourrait être
très longue date n'est qu'une date après
tout que l'important est souvent la
précision mademoiselle pas du tout je
suis né c'est le principal bah en fait
relisez moi ce que je vous ai dit tu
dois aller à taille attendait après
avoir mémoire sans titre chapitre 1
je suis né en fait points point final
point final au final
ouf je suis bien contente d'avoir
terminé l'écriture de mes mémoires
inutile de vous le dire cher téléphone
les mémoires sans titre de mademoiselle
de la cigogne n'ont jamais été publiés
c'est dommage nous aurions connu la date
de naissance de notre charmante amy mais
oui mais oui enfin peut-être qu'un jour
il ne me reste plus qu'à vous donner
rendez vous pour la prochaine édition du
petit écho de la forêt hoyau voyant
quelles sont les nouvelles d'aujourd'hui
authieux quequ'un fifi la fourmi a
chanté tout l'été
les temps changent autrefois c'était les
cigales qui chantait tout était arrivé
tu as chanté tout l'été
oui mon cher je suis devenu une grande
vedette de music hall
j'ai des fans je donne des autographes
je suis une star db c'est assez active
en faire une tête qu'un public ne plus
les singles elle chante toujours la même
source et toi qu'est ce que tu chantes
tu yuko les doux pas mount kimbie ben on
écoute chasser les villas forme et
chasser la fatigue oui oui qui titille
que ces fichiers a formé alors ça ballon
rond ce nom et sabha l'entreprise et ses
rues de bois en font qu il connaît
décidément bien là
moyens il lâché l'hébreu vedette six
fils à fournir un tracé lgv d'infos ici
la fois bien fait dit oui mais difficile
est formé à bien des ennuis
c'est vrai j'ai chanté tout l'été mais
personne n'est venu m'écouter et
maintenant ma main tu ne vis plus rien à
manger je vais mourir de faim la forme
est bien mal parti cependant à l'atelier
des frères k stores tout le monde
s'inquiétait de ce que devenait fifi
d'affirmer ses missions assignées et ya
eu aucun succès on peut très bien vivre
sans la gloire
oui mais on ne peut pas vivre sans jus
syfy vraiment n'a plus d'appétit si elle
ne chante plus mais elles dansent devant
le buffet pourquoi parce qu'il est vide
sans effet nous n'avons qu'à le groupe
hli elle refusant les for me sens très
orgueilleux comment faire pour
l'empêcher de mourir de fer et des mois
j'ai eu l'idée
vim on va en galilée le fait mais pour
qu'une fête soit une fête
il faut une vedette une grande vedette
et c'est ainsi que tv en vue que dans ce
bris je veux bien accepté de chanter
pour votre petite fête
mais je veux un contrat signé par tout
le monde
pfff tu l'auras arrive dip je suis une
vedette très cher ton prix sans rallye
nantes alors je de 3 kg de mouches san
de dernis haut et c'est un prix d'ami
quelques jours plus tard je vais vous
interpréter mon grand succès la fourme
faq et
ap
diviser l'afrique est une info oui oui
oui oui ici je suis bien
merci merci je vais vous annoncer une
grande nouvelle
je redoute les sem
ouais parce que je n'ai aucun talent je
n'ai jamais été une grande vedette je
vous ai tous menti et sans vous je
serais morte agathe saint béat mais si
mais si je vous le quittez notre fort
ajoutant je vous jure que je ne
repartirai jamais vu de la fin merci mes
amis et maintenant j'avais tout bourré
d'idées
de mémoire de hibou ce fut la plus jolie
fait qu'on ait jamais vu dans notre
chère forêt ses fils à fourmies pu dire
qu'une fois dans sa vie elle avait eu un
grand succès bottes
à bientôt cher fifi fans plus pour une
prochaine édition de notre petit écho de
la forêt il coûtait cher telle est fan
mademoiselle de la cigogne a pris de
bonnes résolutions
mais telle résolution avoir meilleur
caractère être plus simple moins
autoritaire - orgueilleuse
elle n'a que l'embarras du choix n'est
ce pas bonjour ma bonne tosca bonjour
anne chazel de la cigogne commenté vous
très mal et pourquoi donc
j'ai tous les défauts tous en sim
pourquoi je suis venu vous demander de
me le dire
c'est difficile vous savez mademoiselle
mais non mais non mais nous je vous fais
confiance et vous me rendrez service
alors que lui reproche-t-on
si je te permettre sans vous fassi mais
jamais je ne me fâche allez allez allez
allez vous avez mauvais caractère
mauvais caractère c'est incroyable mais
c'est en ce sens et c'est inimaginable
puis ce fut au tour de syfy la fourmi
d'être interrogé il me semble que vous
parlez trop d romaine c'est à vous les
20 juste je parle tout le temps d'autres
choses
de tout de la couleur du milieu de ce
que j'ai fait de ce que je ferai de ce
que je pense je m'intéresse aussi aux
autres par exemple en ce moment je vous
écoute parce que j'ai pas bien vous qui
est bien dit les frères k stores fürth
aussi interviewé par la cigogne mois
égoïste mais je passe mon temps à donner
je donne des conseils je donne mon avis
du tout de mon temps oui mon temps à
vous êtes aussi peut-être un petit peu
trop gourmand
moi gourmande alors là laissez moi rire
ben ça c'est important
si j'étais gourmandes comme vous le
prétendez
j'aurais déjà mangé tous bords a dit
avant d'évoquer un nom j'ai horreur de
ça mais si vous avez des raisins je
n'irai pas non
quand elle rencontre à boris le loup la
cigogne insista pour qu'il lui dise la
vérité
mais si dites moi mon bras mme bariza
les trouvez moi au moins un défaut si
vous le pouvez voir avoir mauvais
caractère faux orgueilleuse photo pas de
vous-mêmes faux égoïste faux gourmande
faut ensuite six mois trouve plus rien à
côté faut donc je suis parfaite et notre
parfaite cigognes à la voir la brave
tosca pour lui dire tous ses défauts
nous exhortons yeuse frais bavarde
gourmande égoïste paresseuse
bref vous avez tous les défauts ma
pauvre fille
vous en avez de la chance d'être
parfaite
je sais c'est dans ma nature mais metz à
défaut apic lequel on se sent seul trait
sont terriblement seul
alors je dis prendre une grande
résolution à laquelle je vais partager
avec vous partagez crois ma perfection
et vous ma chère petite koska vous me
donnerez la moitié de vos villes défaut
si nous serons à égalité qu'en pensez
vous décidément notre ami la cigogne
retombe toujours sur ses pattes
quoi qu'il en soit au ska et
mademoiselle de la cigogne sont les
meilleurs amis du monde et c'est le plus
important non à bientôt cherté les
femmes pour une prochaine édition du
petit écho de la forêt où boris le loup
souffre de sa mauvaise réputation hommes
il faut dire que les loups ne sont pas
très aimé on dit trop de choses
terribles sur leur compte mais oui
certes et les fans et on dit
les loups mais aussi les tanks et un
corbeau et le renard
il aime les castors et surtout les
cigognes
mais vous croyez n'importe quoi qui
deviennent suffit vous avez donc oublier
ce qui est arrivé au petit chaperon
rouge une seule allée comme et 10 ans et
je vais vous le prouver qu'elle tient
voilà ce que nous allons faire et c'est
ainsi que déguisé en petit chaperon
rouge
mademoiselle de la cigogne partie dans
la forêt joue et échapper lawn rouge
boom
bonjour messieurs les loulous ce qui
vous allez comme ça tout seul je vais
c'est ma mère-grand lui porter cette
galette est enfin vous connaissez
l'histoire qu'une histoire est bien en
général
s'il faut croire ce qu'on raconte les
loups mme white cloud aux 100 km
un quart d'heure plus tard à la bise ou
de la merco toc toc toc il a lieu
puisque de choc l'homme loup rouge tient
à la cheville est et le beau et à
bobinette cherra au jour malgré mon
chapeau rouge
moineau portugal et études pas de beurre
merci posez la sur la table moi vouloir
avoir vol mais mangez vous malgé des
baisers parce que moi adoré mes regrets
il faut pas m'embrasser bon récit forme
eu des bons
et pourquoi mais parce que c'est comme
ça c'est écrit un livre un mois pour
savoir lire
fifi raconté à boris l'histoire du petit
chaperon rouge
et quand notre ami la cigogne frappe à
la porte tak tak qui a tué le petit
chaperon rouge est alors toi trait aux
bonnes moeurs grand que vous avez de
grands bras c'est pour mieux embrasser
vous enfin moi aux bonnes moeurs grand
que vous avez de grandes dents c'est
pour mieux manger vous enfin à moi ça y
est je vous prends sur le fait méchant
loup jeu mais ça ne se passera pas comme
ça va dit tous venez voir boris est un
monstre je savais que j'en étais sûr il
a mangé ma grand-mère ben je me dire
fille c'est à fall boris comment as tu
pu moeurs et fifi ne voulant plus ça va
tu n'es plus dignes de notre ami tu dois
quitter notre forêt et ne plus jamais
revenir j'avais beaucoup tu n'aurais pas
dû manger notre mère grand mais je ne
suis pas votre berrera mais que fais tu
là fille si tu devrais les dragues à
l'estomac méchant loup boris jeu somme
que moi avoir faim il va toujours
demeurer mais son petit pull qui veut tu
commençais mon cher brice et moi vouloir
d'abord signé galette à suc petit pot de
bleu wahou loire insulaire partager avec
vous parce que moi vous aimez bien tout
ce même mois
même mot merci merci merci alors à table
parce que nous tout savoir et faim de
loup et à partir de ce jour personne
dans notre forêt ne peut jamais plu ou
racontars
à bientôt je vous donne rendez vous pour
une nouvelle édition
une petite et coups de la forêt voyons
voyons quelles sont les nouvelles
d'aujourd'hui aux madmoizelles de la
cigogne engagé un bon à tout faire un
bon à tout faire mais oui mais oui il y
avait des bonnes à tout faire maintenant
il ya aussi des bonds à tout faire il
faut de tout pour faire un monde
tout n'est ce pas sur téléphone alors
bon bras à vous en êtes vous
eh bien voyez j'ai désiré la cuisine
tirer les parquets astiquer les meubles
baisse et leur ardeur et maintenant je
vais vite me reposer type des jo s'est
passé quand je suis fatiguée
mademoiselle
et oui notre bon à tout faire commence à
regretter d'avoir accepté de travailler
chez la cigogne
mais comme je le connais il va chercher
un moyen de se libérer à aaa
alors vous ne voulez pas travailler à la
la la la la je ne sais pas je me sens
nous tous on dit quoi ma danse entre
mâles
ce n'est pas vrai vous jouer la comédie
pour ne pas travailler on va sûrement
raison mesure lyon je ne suis pas
excusez moi madame ragot nom soit une
guenon mais quelle horreur et notre mii
la cigogne à la demander de l'aide aux
frères cash tôt il est vraiment très
mademoiselle mademoiselle à la baleine
mais pas du tout il faut pas le
contrarier un surtout on n'attend pas
nos baleines mais oui mais oui je suis
une balle est la grande baleine une
grosse bague nous il n'ya rien normes
baleine
une énorme balle et un coup je pars d'un
bal un peu folle et mademoiselle de la
cigogne conduisit notre malade cette
hausse que la tortue qui avait quelques
connaissances médicales
alors alors ce pauvre type attraper une
limite aiguë
c'est grand mais comment at-il attrapé
cette maladie
tara microbes qui s'appelle la flemme
c'est contagieux
si on reste à ne rien faire alors je
doive agitée en travaillant une autre
cigogne pour ne pas attraper de phlébite
aiguë se mit à faire tout le travail
qu'elle avait ordonné à zip qui
confortablement allongé soit lui se
dorloter
[Musique]
or je suis épuisé mais il faut vous
reposer métier ne l'est elle tombe il
n'en est pas question je ne veux pas et
rater votre phlébite aiguë il ne faut
pas que j'arrête de travailler les verts
et dont mademoiselle la guêpe
le travail c'est la santé l'incident n y
fit mine de partir mais se cacher
derrière un arbre et l'écoutent et tu en
feras je ne peux quand même pas rester
toute ma vie coucher salle est pas jouer
les grands malades
je commence à m'ennuyer tant pis pour
toi ça t'apprendra et bédié ce que vous
avez vous vous sentez mal contre et mme
mazel de la cigogne ginésy pas une
cigogne
excusez moi monsieur nous sommes à fayet
elle a attrapé une phlébite aiguë il
faut vous coucher tout la fuite mais il
ya encore beaucoup de travail à faire
monsieur mais l'effort vous inquiétez
pas je vais le faire à notre place c'est
guéri maintenant si grippe a
les choses sont rentrées dans l'ordre
moi aussi je sais jouer la comédie
hyper devenu mon propre à tout faire et
moi je suis devenu une grande malade j 9
les mythes aiguilles quel bonheur
oui les sons sont rentrées dans l'ordre
mademoiselle de la cigogne se fait
servir par zip lelièvre qui sert de bon
à tout faire
à bientôt cherté les femmes nous irons
ensemble une nouvelle édition du petit
écran de la forêt liu wei hockey une
nouvelle route yeux tient qu'en cours de
jardinage qui va gagner cette année cher
téléphone mais c'est moi qui vais gagner
concours serbe boris comme tous les ans
moinet par avoir des joueurs d'un mais
vous l'avez conférant luçon mademoiselle
de la cigogne à ses rosiers boris à la
rendre visite à tous que la tortue la
lis tu demande beaucoup de soin tu sais
boris moi pas se voir il faut semer les
graines
quand elles ont poussé replantés ne les
tue les arroser biner autour des pieds
elles deviennent bel bien vertes les
feuilles croquante unsung ensuite se
présente mon jardin au congo zut je le
gagne et je mens jamais été boris qui ne
mangeait pas de l'étude ne pouvait être
cultivé il se rendit dans le jardin de
zips le lieu répond pas encore de l'état
et du serbe au lait et parce que j'adore
farid vip mais moi vouloir jardin de fle
alors qu'un utile desrosiers mes bottes
moi c'est le second y implanter du jour
rades boire plus belles l'étude la ford
de plus en plus tracas si boris à la
dire bonjour à louis le runner qui
travaillait aussi dans son jardin toi
plein de fleurs artificielles
bien sûr ainsi je n'ai pas de travail et
mon jardin est extraordinaire
tu ne trouves pas ah oui mais toi pas
fait le jardinage
mais si mais si je plante je plante des
fleurs artificielles
cette année c'est moi qui gagnerait le
concours ou que je suis rusé et boris
les saint-louis le renard à ses fleurs
artificielles et à ses ruses il est vrai
mélancolique dans la forêt coup salut
baril c'est l'humain oui bon je serai le
seul à concourir avec un jardin suspendu
doit être très mal c'est pas mécontent
toi gagne concours évidemment wood est
ton jardin
moi pas avoir encore trouvé dieu c'est
cher je viens tu en as trop vagues ou je
ne sais pas l'important c'est que tu
cherches à bien et le brave boris
chercha nuitées jour maj il ne trouva
rien max boublil six mois celle subie
yeux ou à trouver moi avoir trouvé
quelque chose morceau bois mort mais
c'est moi m'occuper des morceaux bois
brottes peut-être moi faire morceau bois
vivant
pourquoi ne pas essayer et boris
plantain de morceaux de bois mort dans
son jardin et nuitée jour il s'en occupe
en or un matin j'ai un ami en tant que
membre du jury qui doit élire le
meilleur jardinier de notre belle forêt
ou proclamant le jardel mademoiselle de
la cigogne était remplie droz que celui
de tosca la tortue était remplie bhl et
hugo maillard est il que celui de zips
lelièvre avait dû taille du serpolet
comme d'habitude mais ils avaient tous
mage et comme d'habitude ne parlons pas
des fleurs artificielles de louis le
renard qui a trop rusé comme d'habitude
ni du tournesol de maths le corbeau qui
ai marre de soif et quand même dû alors
nous proclamant meilleur
indignée de la forêt auris le loup qui a
réussi à faire revivre un morceau de
bois mort paulo permettre d'admirer la
plus belle fleur du monde une orchidée
verbard et oui oui et oui cher téléphone
avec beaucoup d'amour et de persévérance
on peut créer les plus belles choses du
monde à bientôt offerte et les femmes
pour une prochaine édition du petit écho
de la forêt vais ici aujourd'hui certes
et les fans nous jetons un coup d'oeil
sur les petites annonces au kiosque yeux
tu écoutais achèterait imagination
s'adresser à mademoiselle de la cigogne
mais pourquoi mademoiselle de la cigogne
modèle acheté de l'imagination
ma pauvre tosca je vous admire comme
c'est gentil mais à votre place j'aurais
honte pourquoi on n'a pas idée de porter
sa maison sur le dos c'est pratique mais
vous avez passé l'âge de faire du
camping ma fille ça m'est égal
en tout cas lorsque je voyage je n'ai
pas à chercher d'hôtel mais vous êtes
trop pauvre pour voyager j'ai quand même
été en chine en chine
à tahiti à tahiti
j'ai même été sur la lune sur la lune au
possible
vous n'avez pas d'elle pour vos lui
peut-être pg de l'imagination une à
sigogne avait reçu un choc
elles n'avaient pas d'imagination elle
décida de s'en procurer sur le champ à
n'importe quel prix je voudrais un petit
renseignement à votre service mam'zelle
est ce que par hasard vous auriez de
l'imagination au pour sûr on en a trop
c'est vrai ça alors je vous en achète au
mas mon imagination je me languis moi
aussi mais je pourrais vous l'a payé
très cher j'ai des moyens nous n'avons
pas notre imagination
la chine gong ne se tape pas pour battus
et à la voir louis leur honneur de
l'imagination
j'en ai bien sûr alors vendez dame
impossible j'en ai tout le temps besoin
mais vous en faites quoi
grâce à mon imagination je peux tu peux
tout réaliser je deviens poule éléphants
puce myosotis à bail alors je ne vendrai
pas pour tout l'or du bourde désespéré
mademoiselle de la cigogne rentrer chez
elle quand elle rencontre boris le loup
soit moi c'est une seconde au soir boris
vous n'êtes pas très gai aujourd'hui non
je suis complètement abattu vous avoir
perdu votre fortune pas du tout où te
levier vos plumes non je perds la tête
pourquoi figurez vous mon cher beau
risque
je me suis aperçu que je n'avais pas
d'imagination il m'en fous absolument
sinon de quoi rêver waouh alpes et
l'imagination mais c'est merveilleux je
voulais c'est tout de suite moins c'est
pas possible
mais pourquoi moi avoir imagination
d'autres voies - la voie interdite
comment avez vous fait imagination cette
ruse et avec lui à se désespérer notre
pauvre cigale rentrer chez elle et tous
cas la torture y est au d
c'est trop injuste tout le monde a de
l'imagination sont fous moi mademoiselle
de la cigogne
il faut que cette fleur jaune sur votre
télé 11 oui elle est très jolie
on dirait une étoile d'or dans un ciel
vers un ciel vert
ce serait joli ciel verte ou constellée
des toiles dehors nous pourrions marché
toutes les deux à travers ce merveilleux
jardin et qui s'étendrait jusqu'à
l'infini mais quoi il faut trouver cette
merveilleuse histoire comme on
d'imagination dans mon imagination
mais l'homme est moi aussi j'ai dit
validation je ne le savais pas je suis
heureuse
si on fera comme tout le monde et oui
cette chaire cigognes avait de
l'imagination et ne le savais pas
je suis certain que dès maintenant elle
va devenir douze patientes modeste il
faut que je m'arrête je crois que je
commence à avoir trop d'imagination
à bientôt pour une prochaine édition du
petit écho de la forêt
[Musique]
toi nous voyons que se passe-t-il dans
nos préférés tiens tiens tiens
boris le loup est lourdement triste aux
pauvres boris il a toujours des
problèmes n'est ce pas cher téléphone
auquel belles jantes et nomade journée
est lourd du montreur effet un soleil
éclatant soleil et rue lourdement un
poteau qui préfèrent la pluie pas non
plus être lourdement bouillotte silva ou
être lourdement mal
hybris s'éloigna il passa devant la
maison de louis salut brice
là vivent elles n'ont vu être lourdement
lourd - on trouve parfois lourdement
optimiste et brise continué sa promenade
qui le conduisit vers l'atelier des
frères k stores ou avoir de la chose
pour voir les treilles la synthèse que
ce que vous faites un gars manger on
fait fi la fourmi parce qu'elle veut
savoir orange et les provisions pour
l'hiver mois power l'hiver prochain et
pourquoi tu es encore leur demande
restée mouvement malheureux parce que
vous n'êtes pas le savoir les deux
frères k stores s'inquiétèrent de la
tristesse de notre ami boris et ils
décidèrent d'aller demander conseil à
tous cas la torture il a dit lourdement
lors demain alors c'est grave je cours
le voir et tous cas la tortue cru chez
boris alors mon pouls paris c'est toi
aussi
loin de moi mais je voudrais savoir
pourquoi tu es si triste
lolll de mots loool de mots raconte moi
ce qui t'arrive
c'est lourd des mois difficiles
j'étais coûte tosca fleuret à moi mourir
lourdement vient voir dans ce cas suivi
boris temps son jardin
e mais mon petit boris tu te trompes
pourquoi toutes les fleurs de tous les
jardins ce fameux bull kouassi nature et
aux boules quoi parce que c'est comme ça
moi vouloir comprendre c'est toutes
fleurs mourir plus jamais fleurs mais
qui te trompes plus de mots l'organe est
oscar mena boris à travers la forêt fifi
la fourmi les accompagna au printemps
j'en lis boris tout les plans donne des
fleurs
oui un été les fers d'un des fruits ou
nuls en l'automne les fruits donnent des
grèves et à 9 heures tout le monde
mourait non petit maurice
en hiver les plantes se repose parce
qu'elles sont venues dieu lourd de mots
c'est ça
mais dès que le printemps revient les
plantes se remette à travailler et
fabrique du fle tu as tout compris à
l'oph le hamois revenu aux bretons oui
c'est lourd mais merveilleux les types h
puis l'automne arrive à puis ce fut le
tour de l'hiver et un matin de printemps
ou flo l'arrivée flaumont très tôt ses
pétales peut au moins être très
lourdement et renault doit être
lourdement et honeywell ou demain
soulagé non
mais alain mignot boris y tenait plus
lourdement
qu'est-ce que tu ais je suis très
content non pas très merveilleusement
content non plus non content lourdement
oui mais oui notre beau boris ne peut
pas s'empêcher de dire sans arrêt
lourdement
c'est ainsi qu'une manif mais oui mais
oui mais oui je sais moi aussi j'ai un
petit je dis toujours mes amis mes
billets alors à bientôt faire petit
téléphone pour une prochaine édition du
petit écho de la forêt couvre y voyant
que s'est il passé dans notre belle
forêt de ce qu'est la tortue a eu le ok
à busan c'est très amusant le hockey
pour les autres et tu en seras si nous
avions fait un petit tour en novembre
d'accord mais vite d'accord des sites
s'y attends moi tu m'a dit d'aller vite
je ne peux pas mais qu'est-ce qui se
prends ton ce cas je ne sais pas c'est
idiot j'ai le cas ok on n'a pas idée
d'avant longuet tu crois que c'est drôle
et prat sur atos cas en lui disant que
le hockey ne dure jamais longtemps
mais au bout d'une heure mais sow qui ne
passe pas du tout mais lisa doby halak
et en os oui je reviens vous m'avez ddm
à la demande des conseils à mademoiselle
de la cigogne qui d'un coup d'aile se
retrouvent après de la malheureuse tosca
mais ne fait pas tout le temps vous me
donner le vertige
chagall fait pas exprès j'ai un moyen
une clé une clé oui une clé je vais
mettre une clé dans votre dos et votre
rockets disparaîtra comme par
enchantement à l'isi mais je n'ai pas de
clé sur moi et vous
moi non je reviens tout de suite et
mademoiselle de la cigogne à la demander
leur avis aux frères k stores nous avons
un truc infaillible locale il faut
mettre tous cas la tête en bas bisel et
roule ou de nomi arriveront le jeu
et par de folles main nous allons
construire une grue pour la montée elle
n'aura qu'à se laisser aller la tête
d'un elle sera prête encore votre grue
dans huit jours invitait ce sera trop
tard
c'est abominable le hockey de tosca
faisait l'objet de toutes les
conversations
moi j'ai un truc infaillible quel truc
il faut lieu et la patte droite en l'air
c'est infaillible pour pour tous corps
pourquoi il n'a pas la pâte assez longue
pour autos max le corbeau s'occuper du
cas de tosca way un truc infaillible
infaillible infaillible reste une heure
sans respirer du tout ton hacker
disparaîtra peut-être mais elle sera
morte si vous complétez ton au même
moment chez les frères k stores il ya un
corps à notre truc infaillible
le cros drogue si quelqu'un fait peur à
tosca socquet partira comme il est venu
ton score peur de rien c'est ce que tu
crois écoute nous bien atteinte et
venant y les deux frères caster
expliquent sur leur truc infaillible à
boris qui partit rejoindre l'auto ce cas
je m'en sortirais jamais aubry ce n'est
pas le moment de présenter
je n'ai pas envie de rire s'il encaisse
et tout mais justement frères castro
d'avoir dit saint paul pour guérir et
faillible s'est raté dans ce cas ces
gens mais vous m'avez fait peur pourquoi
c'est arrivé si vite mais ça m'a effrayé
car ici lol vous avoir fait peur vous
guéret bbb c'est vrai j'ai eu peur
ok pas si c'est grâce à moi
merci mademoiselle de la sig en commun
avait sauvé la vie
je vous l'emprise avant le service
qu'est-ce-qui paris a beau avoir attrapé
roquettes tel hockey nous ne pouvons pas
la laisser racing doit avoir raison
c'est abominable ne pas vous inquiéter
mademoiselle nous envoie le truc
incroyable c'est affreux elle est
vraiment ridicule bien moi aussi j'ai
attrapé look et un bientôt cher
téléphone pour une nouvelle édition du
petit troquet de l'aviron